regardez cette image nous sommes le 16
octobre 2022 et comme chaque année les
2296 responsables du Parti communiste
chinois sont alors rassemblés autour du
président chinois alors à cette occasion
j'ai une pink prend la parole pendant
près de 2h pour présenter son programme
pour les 5 années à venir il est
question de faire de la Chine la
première puissance mondiale il est aussi
question de tourner la page de la
pandémie de coronavirus mais il est
surtout question de Taïwan Jinping
affiche son ambition la Chine va
reprendre le contrôle de Taïwan avant
2049 et ce même si selon le président
chinois cela doit se faire par la force
une déclaration choc donc qui risque de
rester dans les livres d'histoire mais
alors pourquoi la Chine pays d'1,2
milliards d'habitants sont-elles
absolument à prendre le contrôle de
cette petite île de 23 millions
d'habitants de leur côté aussi pourquoi
est-ce que les États-Unis s'en mêlent et
prennent le risque de déclencher une
troisième guerre mondiale en intervenant
militairement en cas d'invasion de
Taïwan viens on se plonge aujourd'hui
dans une histoire de tension et de
menaces une histoire qui risque de
marquer notre époque alors
installez-vous confortablement bienvenue
d'ailleurs à tous les nouveaux qui
s'abonnent à cette chaîne Youtube c'est
un jour il y a plein de contenu et de
vidéos similaires qui arrivent dans les
prochains jours prenez un thé un café ce
que vous voulez et on est parti ensemble
[Musique]
si les États-Unis persistent ils seront
tenus responsables de toutes les
conséquences graves
et avant de commencer je tiens à
remercier très rapidement nordvpn qui a
accepté de nous soutenir en étant
partenaire de cette vidéo alors vous
l'imaginez c'est un format qui nous
demande pas mal de temps et de moyens
surtout qu'on va le poursuivre dans les
prochaines semaines avec plein d'autres
nouveautés alors je ne vais pas vous
présenter les fonctionnalités de nordvpn
que vous connaissez déjà oui un VPN
c'est ce qui permet de changer
d'emplacement virtuel un peu partout
dans le monde et ça peut être très utile
évidemment au quotidien mais ce n'est
pas tout déjà vous pouvez avoir en un
clic une connexion chiffrée pour plus de
sécurité vous avez aussi une
fonctionnalité de protection
anti-monaces pour bloquer les virus par
exemple mais il y a surtout deux
nouveaux outils que je vais vous
présenter très rapidement c'est Nord-Pas
et Nord Locker alors Nord Locker voyez
ça comme un coffre-fort sécurisé en
ligne vous allez pouvoir stocker tous
vos documents les plus importants et
quant à Nord-Pas en fait c'est un
gestionnaire de mot de passe je ne peux
que vous recommandez d'en avoir un chez
mais c'est pas encore le cas à titre
personnel ça a changé ma vie ou en tout
cas mon usage d'Internet au quotidien en
gros un gestionnaire de mots de passe il
génère des mots de passe pour tous vos
comptes sur vos réseaux sociaux ou autre
tous les mots de passe sont en fait
stockés dans votre gestionnaire de façon
sécurisée et je dis que ça change la vie
parce que ça veut dire que vous avez des
mots de passe très fort déjà sur tous
vos sites par ailleurs vous ne les
perdez pas et vous connectez facilement
et automatiquement à tous vos sites
préférés bref c'est plus sécurisé et
plus pratique en tout cas un grand merci
à nordvpn pour son soutien n'hésitez pas
à checker le lien qui s'affiche à
l'écran maintenant et qui est aussi en
description il vous permet de bénéficier
de quatre mois gratuits sur tout
abonnement de deux ans avec en plus une
remise exclusive bref merci à eux et je
vous laisse tout de suite avec la vidéo
ça c'est donc l'île de Taïwan elle est
aussi appelée d'ailleurs
île de Formose elle est située à 130 km
au large de la Chine séparé parce que
l'on appelle le détroit de Taïwan bon
pas d'inquiétude on va évidemment se
plonger dans l'histoire récente les
derniers événements les menaces
d'invasion de Taïwan par la Chine ou
encore bien les menaces d'intervention
de la part des États-Unis mais il faut
bien comprendre que ce n'est pas un
sujet nouveau en réalité ça pas très
longtemps certains estiment que
l'histoire compliquée entre Taïwan et la
Chine débute en 1683 lorsque la dynastie
au pouvoir en Chine la dynastie des
Chings prend le contrôle en 1683 donc de
l'île de Formose l'île que l'on appelle
aujourd'hui Taïwan elle prend le
contrôle de l'île par les armes et des
sites donc de la rattacher à l'empire
chinois près de 200 ans plus tard en
1895 la Chine subit une défaite
militaire face au Japon dans ce que l'on
appelle aujourd'hui la première guerre
sino-japonaise une guerre passionnante à
raconter d'ailleurs on en reparlera
sûrement dans d'autres vidéos mais à ce
moment là et bien la Chine est donc
contrainte de céder l'île de Taïwan au
Japonais sur les 500 dernières années
donc l'île a d'abord été chinoise puis
japonaise mais nouveaux rebondissements
plus récemment en 1945 le Japon après sa
défaite lors de la Seconde Guerre
mondiale rend l'île de Formose à la
Chine le truc c'est que cette île de
Formose est rendu à la Chine dans une
période disons très tendue en Chine en
effet la Chine est ravagée depuis
plusieurs années par une guerre civile
ou deux hommes et deux camps
s'affrontent et je vais vous les
présenter vous allez voir c'est très
important pour la suite de l'histoire
l'homme que vous voyez juste ici c'est
Chancy il est à la tête du coming Tang
un parti qui règne sur la grande
majorité de la Chine depuis la fin des
années 1920 check et même élu président
de la République de Chine en 1948 face à
lui on retrouve Mao Zedong le leader du
Parti communiste chinois fondé en 1921
qui a pourtant d'ailleurs été à
plusieurs périodes un allié du parti de
chiangle check quoi meeting avant de
s'en séparer donc au début des années 40
avec les tensions donc que l'on connaît
or en 1949 c'est le parti communiste qui
remporte la guerre civile Mao zekong
prend donc le pouvoir et proclame la
République populaire de Chine d'ailleurs
petite anecdote un petit peu hors sujet
mais je me permets vous allez voir c'est
assez étonnant le petit livre rouge qui
était donc le livre de propagande
communiste de Mao qui a été diffusé à
partir des années 60 c'est le livre le
plus vendu au monde après la Bible on
estime qu'il y a eu plusieurs milliards
de vente et donc qu'à l'apogée de la
diffusion du livre lors de l'ère de Mao
en Chine et bien la planète comptait
trois milliards de personnes et on
comptait en moyenne plus d'un livre par
personne sur la planète bref Mao
remporte donc la guerre civile il prend
la tête de la Chine et son rival
décide alors de fuir justement donc à
Taïwan mais changache ne se contente pas
de fuir tout seul en fait il installe à
Taïwan ce qu'il va appeler la République
de Chine par opposition donc à la
République populaire de Chine de Mao il
a alors pour ambition de représenter
toute la Chine il amène donc avec lui
son armée 2 millions de personnes ainsi
que il faut le noter des trésors
artistiques de la Financière des trésors
qui sont toujours aujourd'hui exposés au
Musée national de Taipei la capitale
donc de Taïwan
voilà donc comment de façon assez
étonnante en 1949 on a donc deux Chine
qui estiment être la vraie Chine pour
récapituler on a d'un côté la République
de Chine sur l'île de Taïwan dirigée
donc par chiangle check qui considère
qu'il est le représentant de la
véritable Chine et qui d'ailleurs à ce
moment-là n'exclut pas de reprendre un
jour le contrôle de la Chine
continentale et de l'autre côté on a
donc la République populaire de Chine
sur les territoires de la Chine
continentale le tout dirigé par Mao avec
le Parti communiste chinois Mao qui
considère Taïwan à ce moment-là comme
une partie de son territoire et comme à
la 23e province de la Chine on se
rapproche maintenant des tensions
actuelles on avance dans les années
70-80 à mesure que le développement
économique de la Chine lui permet en
fait de s'affirmer comme une puissance
mondiale et bien la Chine comme on
l'entend aujourd'hui prend le dessus sur
taïw un grand tournant arrive par
exemple en 1971 à l'Organisation des
Nations Unies c'est ce que l'on appelle
la résolution
2758 la Chine continentale donc la
République populaire de Chine va alors
récupérer le siège de la Chine au
Conseil de sécurité de l'ONU après la
Seconde Guerre mondiale un siège et donc
très important qui était occupé
jusqu'ici par Taïwan et qui va donc être
récupéré par la Chine telle qu'on
l'entend aujourd'hui ce qu'on va donc
c'est que à mesure que la Chine se
développe économiquement elle est aussi
en mesure d'affirmer son pouvoir à
l'échelle internationale et on en
reparlera juste après parce que vous
allez le voir c'est très important dans
le cadre du conflit actuel un deuxième
tournant absolument historique va
arriver en 1979 en fait ça se passe avec
ce président américain Jimmy Carter
c'est sous cette présidence que les
États-Unis vont établir des relations
diplomatiques avec la Chine telle qu'on
entend aujourd'hui et donc rompre leur
relation diplomatique avec Taïwan la
première puissance mondiale les
États-Unis donc à l'époque reconnaissent
que ça y est la Chine est bien un état
mais Taïwan en tout cas ne l'est plus
officiellement forte de tous ces succès
diplomatiques alors que la Chine est
clairement en position de force elle va
alors proposer à Taïwan une option
absolument cruciale j'ai nommé l'option
un pays de système en gros la Chine va
dire à Taïwan écoute je te laisse
conserver une autonomie importante
développer ton propre système politique
ou quoi mais cela dit malgré tout ça tu
restes à moi à ce moment-là Taïwan
refuse mais bon les années passent les
tensions sont disons modérés jusque très
récemment et c'est pour ça qu'on en
parle aujourd'hui avec l'arrivée au
pouvoir de deux figures une figure en
Chine et une figure à Taïwan ces deux
figures risquent de changer le cours de
l'histoire la femme que vous voyez juste
ici c'est de sign Wayne c'est donc la
présidente de Taïwan depuis 2016 et
comment vous le dire visiblement elle a
pas vraiment peur de la Chine en tout
cas elle ne le repas elle est surnommée
d'ailleurs par plusieurs médias la bête
noire de Pékin et ce notamment en raison
des positions de son parti politique
mending
la deuxième personnalité qui a changé
beaucoup de choses dans les relations
entre la Chine et Taïwan vous le
connaissez en l'occurrence peut-être
davantage on a parlé en introduction on
en parle beaucoup dans les actualités du
jour sur nos formats au quotidien c'est
lui jijing ping l'actuel président
chinois depuis 2012 suzing ping est
animé par une ambition très forte faire
entrer ce qu'il considère comme le
socialisme chinois dans une nouvelle ère
faire de la Chine en fait la première
puissance mondiale devant les États-Unis
et ainsi et bien redonner à la Chine la
splendeur passée de l'empire chinois
pour lui ça passe notamment par une
reprise en main de Hong Kong on en a
beaucoup parlé là aussi dans l'actualité
j'avais fait d'ailleurs un reportage sur
le sujet il y a quelques années
peut-être que vous l'aviez vu pour ceux
qui étaient là au tout début de la
chaîne mais ça passe aussi voir surtout
par une prise en main de l'île de Taïwan
et cette ambition très très forte le
président chinois a affirmé que ce soit
en 2017 au début de son second mandat ou
d'ailleurs il a obtenu des pouvoirs
renforcés il y a un contrôle en vrai
quasi total sur le pays il a encore donc
affirmé en octobre 2022 il y a quelques
jours ping veut absolument reprendre le
contrôle sur Taïwan y compris donc par
la force si besoin il est possible que
pour Sidi King Taïwan soit vraiment la
pièce manquante dont il s'est donné la
mission de reconquérir et donc c'est
pour ça que zimping souhaite être
l'homme qui va accomplir qui va achever
même le travail de Mao qui a été
d'unifier la Chine en étant l'homme si
Jean Ping qui reprend Taïwan et donc qui
unifie pleinement la République
populaire de Chine dans la tête de
gidine ping il y a une date précise pour
avoir achevé ce retour de Taïwan sous le
contrôle de Pékin et cette date c'est
celle donc de 2049 faut savoir que le
gouvernement chin pas aime beaucoup ses
anniversaires ces datent symboliques qui
permettent de marquer le coup et 2049
marquera le centième anniversaire d'un
événement extrêmement important pour la
Chine d'aujourd'hui alors peut-être que
vous avez fait le lien je vous avais
noté les différentes dates il s'agira en
effet du centième anniversaire de la
fondation de la République populaire de
Chine en 1949 donc par ma haute c'est
tongs alors pourquoi la Chine tient-elle
tant à Taïwan en effet finalement c'est
ce qu'on disait en début de vidéo si on
voit ça vraiment de loin c'est 23
millions d'habitants une petite île vu
comme ça ça paraît quasiment
insignifiant par rapport à la Chine les
en réalité détrompez-vous il y a de très
nombreuses raisons qui expliquent tout
cela il y a déjà donc des motivations
idéologiques et historiques on l'a vu à
l'instant avec le discours du président
chinois jijing ping ensuite il y a une
dimension réellement politique en fait
le modèle politique de Taïwan tel qu'il
est aujourd'hui dérange très très
fortement la Chine c'est un monde
chinois qui véritablement un contre
modèle absolu à ce qui le ce qui se
passe aujourd'hui en République
populaire de Chine c'est à dire que sur
le plan politique Taïwan est une
démocratie très jeune démocratie c'est
une démocratie depuis les années 1990
alors même que c'est un pays qui a vécu
pendant plus de 40 ans sous la loi
martiale c'est-à-dire que des années 50
jusqu'à la fin des années 80 Taïwan a
vécu sous une dictature militaire mais
celle-ci progressivement réformée pour
devenir une démocratie comme on peut en
connaître dans le monde en Europe et
donc c'est presque d'ailleurs une un
miracle en terme politique puisque non
seulement Taïwan est passé d'une
dictature militaire à un régime
démocratique mais en fait en plus elle
l'a faite cette transition par le haut
c'est à dire que ce sont les présidents
taiwanais qui progressivement ont lancé
des réformes pour aller de leur propre
chef volontairement vers vers la
démocratie et très concrètement le
magazine britannique qui effectue chaque
année en classement des démocraties a
classé Taïwan 8ème pays le plus
démocratique au monde en 2021 huitième
c'est donc un excellent classement et
d'ailleurs Taïwan est classé dans la
catégorie des démocraties complètes la
France est d'ailleurs classée dans la
catégorie des démocraties défaillantes
bon et la Chine je ne vous apprends rien
et très loin d'être une démocratie
aujourd'hui elle figure en 148e position
de ce classement sur 177 pays qui sont
répertoriés
donc évidemment quand on voit le régime
politique en République populaire de
Chine qui est beaucoup plus un régime
autoritaire voire dictatorial avec un
parti unique qui est le Parti communiste
qui contrôle l'intégralité du pouvoir
politique mais du pouvoir exécutif du
pouvoir judiciaire et aussi du pouvoir
législatif d'un point de vue politique
évidemment c'est un contre modèle qui
est extrêmement désagréable pour Pékin
puisqu'en plus c'est un modèle qui est
viable qui est fonctionnel bref vous
l'avez compris conquérir Taïwan ce
serait ainsi un moyen pour la Chine de
mettre fin à cet exemple de démocratie
extrêmement performante qui est située à
quelques dizaines de kilomètres juste à
côté d'elle bon mais la troisième raison
qui fait que Taïwan intéresse très
fortement la Chine c'est peut-être
d'ailleurs la raison la plus importante
elle est liée à la position très
stratégique disons de cette île à
l'échelle internationale sur la façade
littoral de la Chine il y a ce que l'on
appelle la première chaîne d'île qui est
constituée de l'archipel japonais puis
de justement l'île de Taïwan et
l'habitude de tout l'archipel philippin
suivi ensuite par l'Indonésie et qui se
ferme avec la Malaisie face à cette
première chaîne d'île la Chine est d'une
certaine manière un petit peu confinée
dans ce que l'on appelle la mère de
Chine orientale face au Japon et la mère
de Chine méridionale dans le Sud-Est
asiatique en raison de cette première
chaîne d'île la Chine n'a pas un accès
complètement libre à l'océan Pacifique
et donc c'est pour une pour une
puissance comme la Chine c'est quelque
chose qui est problématique d'autant
plus que cette première chaîne d'île
elle est constituée donc je l'ai dit
donc de la Corée du Japon qui sont deux
alliés très proches des Etats-Unis et
même deux pays qui accueillent parmi les
plus importantes bases militaire
américaine or du territoire américain
donc forcément c'est un environnement
qui est perçu par la Chine comme
relativement hostile pour la Chine
aujourd'hui donc prendre le contrôle de
Taïwan répond à plusieurs enjeux et
plusieurs objectifs qu'ils soient
idéologiques politiques géopolitique
mais aussi des enjeux économiques il y a
un enjeu en effet économique puisque
Taïwan est aujourd'hui à 21e économie
mondiale et une grande puissance
technologique on va revenir là-dessus
juste après mais alors dans ce contexte
là très tendu quelle est la position des
autres pays sur la question et bien là
aussi c'est absolument passionnant à
observer en fait aujourd'hui Taïwan a
une opposition extrêmement particulière
sur la scène internationale elle est à
la fois défendue par de nombreux pays et
l'île a d'ailleurs développé des
relations économiques un peu partout
dans le monde le dernier exemple
peut-être le plus marquant c'était
pendant la crise de coronavirus Taïwan
était en effet un grand producteur de
masque qu'ils avaient en stock
conséquent de matériel médical et
notamment deux masques ils en ont donc
profité pour faire des dons de dizaines
de millions de masques à différents pays
du monde ça a permis en fait à Taïwan de
s'affirmer comme un État indépendant
capable donc de nouer des relations
économiques partout dans le monde et
c'est d'ailleurs ce que certains ont
appelé une diplomatie du masque de la
part de Taïwan pour s'affirmer sur la
scène internationale mais pourtant
regardez cette carte qui s'affiche
actuellement c'est la carte en fait des
pays qui reconnaissent officiellement
Taïwan comme un État indépendant et donc
entretiennent officiellement des
relations diplomatiques avec elle ces
états ils sont en bleu ciel et aussi
étonnant que ça puisse paraître il y a
donc seulement 14 États et ce ne sont
pas des puissances mondiales il y a
notamment le Paraguay le Honduras ou
encore le Guatemala et Haïti autrement
dit les pays qui pèsent le plus disons à
l'échelle internationale ne
reconnaissent pas officiellement Taïwan
ce qu'il faut bien comprendre c'est que
la Chine de jinking conditionne les
relations diplomatiques avec elle à la
non reconnaissance de Taïwan c'est ce
qu'elle appelle le principe d'une seule
Chine concrètement l'idée c'est de dire
bah en fait c'est soit Taïwan soit la
Chine donc soit vous reconnaissez Taïwan
comme État indépendant et alors vous
n'aurez pas de relation diplomatiques
avec nous soit du coup vous reconnaissez
la Chine comme état mais du coup vous ne
reconnaissez pas Taïwan et à ce moment
là on peut travailler ensemble et
développer des relations économiques des
relations avec la Chine qui vous
imaginer sont très importantes la Chine
aujourd'hui c'est la deuxième économie
mondiale c'est le premier exportateur
mondial de produits manufacturés c'est
aussi le premier pays en termes
d'investissement direct à l'étranger et
donc ne pas avoir de relation
diplomatiques avec la Chine ce quasiment
suicidaire aujourd'hui c'est ce qui
explique donc l'absence de
reconnaissance officielle de Taïwan par
différents États notamment les pays
occidentaux pour dire les choses
rapidement ils ont peur de se froisser
avec la Chine mais alors qu'elle est
aujourd'hui plus précisément la position
des États-Unis concernant ce sujet là
évidemment la position des États-Unis
dans cette affaire elle a été définie
pendant des décennies par un concept
volontairement flou d'ailleurs mais un
concept qui tient en deux mots un
concept d'ambiguïté stratégique en gros
il ne reconnaissent officiellement qu'un
seul gouvernement chinois c'est donc
celui de Pékin sans donc reconnaître
Taïwan comme un État indépendant mais
malgré ça et bien il s'oppose à une
invasion de Taïwan par la Chine et en
même temps officiellement pendant des
années bien les Etats-Unis refusaient de
dire expressément si oui ou non ils
interviendraient pour défendre Taïwan en
cas d'attaque par la Chine bref
jusqu'ici c'était flou de la part des
États-Unis mais en même temps c'était le
but jusqu'à récemment donc où ça a
évolué en effet ces derniers temps la
position des États-Unis a évolué vers
davantage de fermeté contre la Chine et
pour défendre Taïwan les États-Unis sont
de plus en plus tentés en fait de
reconnaître Taïwan comme un allié et de
défendre militairement Lille en cas
d'invasion il y a plusieurs reprises le
président américain Joe Biden a laissé
entendre que les États-Unis iraient
défendre militairement Taïwan en cas
d'invasion regardez par exemple cet
extrait ça s'est passé en septembre 2022
et c'est assez marquant pour comprendre
tout ça
en prononçant de tels mots Joe Biden
remet alors en cause toute la doctrine
historique des États-Unis c'est
d'ambiguïté stratégique et d'ailleurs
cette déclaration a surpris beaucoup
d'observateurs d'ailleurs certains n'y
ont pas cru tellement cette doctrine
changer avec ce qui était dit par les
précédents gouvernements américains
beaucoup ont considérait que c'était des
gafs puisque le président Biden est
assez coutumier du fait de de dire des
choses et puis finalement de
rétropédaler derrière à plusieurs
reprises la Maison Blanche a démenti a
dit qu'il n'y avait pas de changement
dans la politique des États-Unis à
l'égard de Taïwan mais au bout de la
quatrième fois que Joe Biden affirme que
oui les Etats-Unis interviendraient on
peut aujourd'hui légitimement
s'interroger si ce n'est pas aujourd'hui
une nouvelle politique en tout cas
l'orientation de la politique américaine
aujourd'hui bon on approche de la fin
mais a quand même cette question quel
intérêt ont finalement les États-Unis à
défendre aussi fermement Taïwan
aujourd'hui pourquoi finalement les
États-Unis tiennent autant à défendre
cette île qui est située à plus de 10
000 kilomètres de leur territoire
évidemment c'est les deux phases d'une
même pièce disons puisque la Chine
s'inquiète de l'émergence d'une Taïwan
rivale avec notamment un modèle
politique politique différent de la
Chine et des envies d'indépendance et
bien de l'autre côté les États-Unis sont
ravis de prôner un modèle qui va dans le
sens de leur idéal mais surtout les
États-Unis sont absolument ravis de voir
une île comme Taïwan perturbée et faire
de la concurrence à la Chine bon et par
ailleurs une fois qu'on a dit tout ça la
deuxième raison qui incite quand même
les États-Unis à défendre Taïwan c'est
une raison plus pragmatique c'est l'idée
de garder le contrôle de la mère de
Chine la mère de Chine donc face à la
Chine et là on rentre au cœur de
nouveaux enjeux géopolitiques qui sont
assez fascinants
enfin dernière enjeu qu'on peut noter
très rapidement Taïwan et pour les
États-Unis comme pour l'Europe
d'ailleurs un partenaire économique très
important et notamment une très grande
puissance technologique en effet Taïwan
maîtrise un savoir-faire en matière de
composants électronique et en
particulier de semi-conducteur et celui
conducteur qui aujourd'hui sont
indispensables dans toutes les nouvelles
technologies d'aujourd'hui et surtout de
demain que ce soit dans les dans la 5G
dans les nouveaux smartphones dans
l'intelligence artificielle la voiture
autonome toutes les technologies
satellitaires et évidemment dans
l'armement ces composants électroniques
sont absolument stratégiques et
aujourd'hui Taïwan est le plus grand
producteur et le meilleur en tout cas
producteur de ces semis conducteurs
alors où en sont réellement les tensions
aujourd'hui et bien depuis deux ans et
face au discours de la présidente
taïwanaise et aux nouvelles ambitions
aussi de Jin ping la Chine a multiplié
les provocations militaires à l'égard de
Taïwan depuis 2021 il y a des centaines
d'avions chinois qui ont survolé sans
prévenir la zone aérienne de défense de
Taïwan
une zone en fait où les avions doivent
normalement s'identifier aux autorités
taïwanaises par ailleurs en août 2022
deux événements ont encore monté
l'attention d'un cran et du même coup
d'ailleurs les démonstrations militaires
de la Chine le premier c'est la visite
officielle à Taïwan de la présidence de
la Chambre des Représentants américaines
Nancy Pelosi l'antipelosi et donc la
présidence de l'équivalent de
l'Assemblée nationale en France c'est
très marquant puisque c'est la troisième
plus haute représentante des États-Unis
et donc quelque part aux yeux de la
Chine ça revient à briser le principe
d'une seule Chine puisque on a une
visite diplomatique à Taïwan dans
représentant des États-Unis en réaction
d'ailleurs à tout cela la Chine a tiré
plusieurs missiles dans la mer autour de
Taïwan elle a par ailleurs déployé des
navires militaires dans le détroit de
Taïwan et 15 avions militaires sont
allés jusqu'à franchir la frontière
officielle entre la Chine et Taïwan
alors pour terminer une question
absolument cruciale la Chine peut-elle
vraiment et réellement envahir Taïwan
alors là on a clairement besoin d'une
carte pour mieux comprendre ce dont on
parle Taïwan et donc séparée de la Chine
par un détroit de 130 km et pour la
Chine ça représenterait un immense défi
militaire et logistique rien à voir
d'ailleurs avec l'invasion de l'Ukraine
par la Russie qui a pu faire par la
terre puisque les deux pays partagent
une frontière terrestre là la Chine
aurait nécessairement besoin de navire
et ce serait tout simplement le plus
grand envahissement militaire mené dans
l'histoire récente par ailleurs la Chine
aurait tout intérêt envahir très fort et
très rapidement pour décourager
justement les États-Unis d'engager leur
armée dans ce conflit d'autant que pour
les États-Unis et bien engager leur
armée prendrait forcément un peu de
temps le temps déjà d'acter la décision
et puis d'organiser ces opérations
militaires alors il y a-t-il avec tout
cela un risque de déclencher un conflit
mondial et bien pour les États-Unis la
décision de défendre militairement
Taïwan ne sera pas facile à prendre dans
tous les cas je bid a beau assuré que
les États-Unis le feront et bien dans
les faits ça voudrait dire basculer le
conflit Shin Taïwan en conflit
véritablement mondial alors pour autant
beaucoup d'incertitudes subsistent en
cas d'invasion de Taïwan par la Chine
les États-Unis vont-ils donc engager
leur armée véritablement sur le terrain
ou alors vont-ils faire comme ils font
actuellement en Ukraine c'est à dire
qu'actuellement et bien il n'y a pas de
militaire américain présent a priori en
Ukraine par contre et bien il y a la
fourniture massive notamment de matériel
militaire pour aider l'Ukraine à se
défendre voilà pourquoi vous allez
beaucoup entendre parler de Taïwan dans
les années qui viennent et je l'espère
ce sera désormais un peu plus clair avec
cette vidéo ça me semblait essentiel de
faire un point détaillé sur le sujet
aujourd'hui d'ailleurs cette vidéo vous
a plu n'hésitez pas à vous abonner pour
ne pas rater les vidéos suivantes on va
reprendre progressivement un rythme
important sur cette chaîne avec des
décryptages des reportages qui arrivent
mais aussi bien des interviews tiens
aussi à remercier Marc julienne de
l'iris pour son temps à Apple qui est
journaliste au sein de l'équipe et qui a
travaillé avec moi à l'écriture de cette
vidéo ainsi qu'à vanon notamment monteur
au sein de l'équipe qui en a assuré le
montage bref pensez donc à vous abonner
je sais pas encore le cas prenez soin de
vous prenez soin de vos proches et puis
on se dit à très vite